Gradle provides two ways
to visualize dependencies.
A traditional dependency report showing
the complete graph of dependencies and
a dependency insight report showing how
a particular dependency is included
in your project.
Here we have a simple Java project
with a single dependency on
the Spring Core Library.
We can generate a dependency report
by running the dependencies task.
Gradle displays
the project dependencies,
including transitive dependencies.
The report also breaks out
dependencies by each configuration.
To see the dependencies for
a particular configuration, we can use
the --configuration command line option.
And there we go we have the dependencies
just for the run time configuration.
The dependency insight report shows how
a particular dependency is included in
our project.
This report is especially helpful
when identifying version conflicts.
To run the dependency insight task we
need to specify the dependency we're
interested in using the dash dash
dependency command line option.
Let's get an insight report on
the commons-logging dependency.
We can tell from this report that
commons-logging is a dependency of
spring-core, which in turn is a
dependency of our compile configuration.
We mentioned that one of the main
uses of dependency reports
is to help identify
dependency version conflicts.
Let's introduce a conflict and see how
this affects the output of our reports.
Let's add an explicit
dependency on version 1.2
of the commons-logging library.
If we now run the Gradle dependencies
task again, as you can see,
commons-logging is now listed
twice in our dependency report.
In this case,
you can see our project depends on 1.2,
whereas spring-core depends on 1.1.3.
This introduces a conflict, which
Gradle will then attempt to resolve.
By default, Gradle resolves version
conflicts to the newest version,
in this case 1.2.
In our report this is
indicated by an arrow,
showing us that version 1.2 is
being chosen over version 1.1.3.
We can get similar information from
the dependency insight report.
Let's run this report and
see the results.
Again, we can see that the dependency
is shown twice in our report.
We see that our compile configuration
depends on version 1.2, and
that our compile configuration
also depends on spring core,
which depends on commons-logging 1.1.3.
Gradle noticed that there
was a version conflict, and
resolved the conflict in
favor of version 1.2.